two and a half years before Ferguson the
shooting death of Trayvon Martin was a
call to action for many people in this
country the unarmed teenager was 17
years old and he was shot and killed in
2012 by George Zimmerman who claimed he
was attacked and that he fired in
self-defense
Zimmerman was tried and acquitted of all
charges
now Trayvon Martin's parents at Sybrina
Fulton and Tracy Martin have teamed up
with jay-z
on the news six part document our the
Trayvon Martin story it chronicles
Trayvon's death and the protest movement
that emerged after it earlier this year
Tracy and Sabrina were honored in New
York's Cathedral of st. John the Divine
for their activism we met with Sabrina
there yesterday
you and Tracy received an award in this
church I decided I could not let my
son's death be in vain
and I've heard you say if it was up to
you none of us would know your name none
of us would know Trayvon's name so how
have you reconciled it now everybody
knows you everybody knows your story I
chose to leave number one I chose to
move to my next chapter because if my
son had died and I had died also and I
was just walking around earth not doing
anything then I would be dead too they
slid a crime scene photo to me and X was
that my son I was reluctant to you know
even speak even to be the voice of my
son you know which seems like that's the
natural thing to do is to speak for
Trayvon who's not here but um I didn't
want to I just felt so weak and hopeless
and helpless
God really had to work on me to
strengthen me to get me to speak up for
other people to speak up for my son to
speak up for myself
Sybrina Fulton can still recall the
moment six years ago when she learned
that her 17 year old son Trayvon Martin
was shot and killed they say that time
heals all wounds
it does not by neighborhood watch
volunteer George Zimmerman Zimmerman
claimed self-defense
my son was innocent my son was the
victim my son didn't shoot and kill
anyone he didn't even own a gun people
look at the situation they get angry
with it but we have to get angry to the
point that we're doing something about
it and that's what I did the death of
your son Trayvon Martin certainly
launched a movement what was it like for
you the first time you went anywhere and
you saw crowds thousands of people
saying I am Trayvon Martin or screaming
his name how did you process that well
it was here in New York did you look so
strong during that time and I often
marveled does she feel as strong as she
looks I did not they didn't see me when
I was very emotional they didn't see me
when I was depressed and so where so
many people were telling me how strong I
was I didn't feel it on the inside and
so I started speaking to myself I
started speaking to God I started saying
to myself I am strong I am strong and
then I started to feel like I really was
strong how do you grieve and recover
from the death of a child I think I had
a great deal of support early on I
started like reaching out to other
mothers that had kids that were victims
of senseless gun violence and it kind of
take the edge off of what I was going
through I had so many people that were
positively like lifting me up even now
through my difficult days when I have my
bad days and you still have bad days
absolutely I'm gonna have bad days the
rest of my life but because it feels
like something what is a good day you're
triggered by a memory or what is it it
doesn't really have to be a memory it
doesn't have to be something that I saw
I could wake up that morning and and
just have a bad feeling because it feels
like I'm missing something it feels like
something is is not right with my life
it feels like something is
in order with my life and so I'm not
afraid to cry I'm not afraid to tell
people that I cry that's just my rainy
day but I know that a better day is
coming how do you feel about George
Zimmerman I don't give him a whole lot
of time a whole lot of focus have you
forgiven him I have not I have not I
know that in my own time in my own grief
and in this whole grieving process that
I have to forgive but by the same token
I'm not at that point yet I'm very
honest with that a lot of people ask me
that question
and I'm very open and honest about it
I'm very real with my feelings and I
know I have not forgiven Sabrina says
she never could have imagined that her
son's death would have had this kind of
impact as a catalyst for the black lives
matter movement even Trayvon's hoodie
would become a symbol I call it
Pandora's box and it is the box of
evidence that was given to me by the
Department of Justice probably three
years after Trayvon was shot and killed
and when I first got the box I said I
wasn't going to open the box and of
course curiosity bothered me for a while
because the box was in the house and I
opened the box and I cried and cried and
cried what was in the Box in the box is
everything that Trayvon had on his
hoodie his pants his t-shirt his socks
his shoes his cell phone his money the
the dream the candy everything is in the
box
Sabrina says she received a request a
few years ago to display those items to
the public in a museum
at first she was not ready I didn't want
anybody to see the things I didn't want
anybody to touch them I just was like no
and so this year we're meeting now
there's a possibility a strong
possibility that they may end up in the
museum because I feel like I have grown
since that time even though I get
birth to Trayvon I just think that he is
everybody's son and I need to share
those things with everybody a lot of
people do feel he's everybody's son
still we reached out to George Zimmerman
for comment we did not hear back from
him the third episode of the docu-series
arrest in power airs Monday on paramount
Network and B et you know it's very
tough when you hear when you see in the
documentary you learn so many things
that you didn't know about Trayvon he
wanted to be he wanted to fly he was
taking flying lessons with a friend that
he had great love for aviation and you
see too about George Zimmerman who now
is signing skittles bags for people and
bragging about how yeah I shot Trayvon
Martin and and then he sold a gun so
it's it's it's you learned so many
things and we've been covering that case
from the very beginning it was just
interesting to see and I asked her that
that iconic picture of Trayvon in the
hoodie where did that come from
that was a selfie that he had taken of
himself I always wondered about that you
know when she says that she's always
going to have bad days yeah I can't
imagine yes and it's but it's so
powerful to hear express these emotions
that she still has all these years later
she said someone should have to pay for
every tears she shed they she still
doesn't feel that justice has happened
in this case I don't know if it will
ever get justice to her satisfaction
it's still very very painful
he says she turned other other mothers
whose children were taken away by gun
violence for instance you know for help
and solace and so many have turned to
her now execs what the work that the
driver Guatemalan nation does similar
issues right that gives her some power
of some comfort that she's doing
something to make sure that he didn't
die in vain and that she knows that
she's helping other mothers yeah such a
powerful interview Gail thank you thanks